target continues to change how it
operates to keep employees and customers
safe during this pandemic the huge
retailer has kept its nearly 2,000
stores open across the country and
online sales have increased more than
listen to this number 275 percent this
month chairman and CEO that's brian
cornell joins us he's outside a target
in sarasota florida good morning to you
brian grinnell really good to see you I
want to start with that huge jump in the
online shopping
were you expecting or hoping for that
kind of number and what does that tell
you about the shoppers these days well
Gail good morning and we've seen
distinct chapters throughout the
pandemic when things first started back
in February we certainly saw consumers
coming to Target to stock up on
household essentials we talked about
food and beverage growing at almost 40%
and then we've seen different behavior
along the way as people started to
shelter in place and stay at home they
were shopping for office supplies as
they were working from home and
educating their kids or games to occupy
time with their family and then clearly
as people spent more time at home and
we're getting advice to avoid being out
in public we started to see digital
sales soared in March they grew over a
hundred percent but in April growing at
over two hundred and seventy five
percent and these are just changes that
I think consumers are making right now
as they combat the virus and focus on
their own health and safety so things
like drive up behind me of just been
exploding as consumers can pull into a
target parking lot we put that order
right in there a trunk they drive away
safely and I think those are types of
services that will continue to grow over
time yeah my friend Wendy only goes to
Target Brian Cornell you'll be glad to
know that she says already you only do
self checkout and you make sure that
everybody is 6 feet apart in the store
you only let X amount of people in at
any given time said it well yeah we've
been very focused on safety first for
our team members and as we recognize we
were here to serve America during the
pandemic the first thing we started to
focus on
was a safety of our team so making sure
we're investing in our team their safety
and then obviously the safety of our
guests so we've made big investments in
our team paying benefits to make sure
that during this crisis they were well
taken care of
but importantly we've taken safety
measures for the guests so we have put
up plexiglass shields at the check Lane
as you're checking out of our stores
there's decals on the floor making sure
people provide that six feet of space
that's so necessary right now we do
meter the number of guests in our stores
at any one time so it's really about
making sure we can create a safe
shopping environment one where our
guests the target guest feels safe but
importantly where our team members feel
safe each and every day well Brian let's
talk about the team members because we
keep hearing a lot of many people on the
team are not happy they're planning to
walk off the job and they've made that
very clear what are you doing to address
their concerns well Gail I always want
to hear from our team and with over 350
thousand team members across America we
get lots of feedback each and every day
I can tell you the feedback I receive
and I heard it this morning talking to
our teams here in Sarasota they are
really proud to work for Target from the
start of this pandemic they recognize
they've been providing important
community services each and every day
allowing Americans to get those
household essentials their medication
the food and beverage they need so I
hear stories of pride and I've talked
about this throughout the pandemic the
real heroes at Target are those
frontline team workers the ones in our
supply chain and our stores every day
taking care of the American family and I
hear great stories of pride and I expect
on May 1st we'll have our teams in place
and we'll be serving America as we do
each and every day through this pandemic
I agree with you Brian those frontline
workers who are serving us every day are
also true heroes you know we all saw you
on the White House lawn last month with
other business leaders talking about
what you were planning to do to help in
this pandemic and at the time you said
that you would host drive-through
testing sites on target property so
there's one in California I believe in
the San Diego area do you have plans to
build others to set up others well Gail
we've said our parking lots are
available for testing and obviously
we've started one with the UC system in
San Diego as you might know we don't
operate our own pharmacies we've got a
great partnership with CBS
they've got pharmacists and technicians
in our stores so we've opened up our
parking lots but we don't have the
team's actually do testing so we're
looking for partners we'll certainly
make sure that our parking lots are
available for testing as we go forward
and I think we all know how important
testing is going to be as we battle this
virus
Brian Cornell thank you very much for
taking your time this morning let me
tell you I know a lot of people are glad
that you're up and running thank you
very much sir